um my favorite all-time question and
it's kind of the go-to question i always
go
at the end of the interview is assuming
you join our team tomorrow how do you
make us better
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc funding silicon
valley
in partnership with lumitec and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford
this one is really all about leadership
welcome our known craft the ceo of big4
strategic consulting and formal general
manager of microsoft
arnold is a business and operations
executive with over 20 years of general
manager and vice president level
experience from fortune 500 companies
like microsoft and sandisk and startups
until
2018 he was with microsoft managing a
business scope of multi-billion us
dollars
and building strategic partnerships with
the leading tech companies
in 2018 arnon moved back to israel where
he currently represents two leading
technology
mncs from asia as our strategic advisor
and technology scout in addition arnon
brings his extensive experience and
serves as an active advisory board
member for startup companies
where he helps ceos and coos to scale up
their growing companies
our non-craft thank you for joining me
today how are you
good how are you michael good to be here
it's a now now everything is fantastic
i'm excited to talk about your journey
and you've had a phenomenal journey and
you know
obviously in looking back i'm it looks
very very linear but as i've learned in
the show
a lot of decision making experiences are
not that obvious and i can't wait to
to pick your brain about you know some
of the difficult decisions that you have
to make some of the career development
insights that you've harnessed over over
your you know your career
which has been incredible you know
through the technion and tel aviv
university to nes
sandisk and mo do mobile and and
microsoft as general manager
you know leading multi-billion dollars
you know in in business and in
partnerships
so obviously you've seen a lot you've
done a lot and
one of your you know fantastic talks on
tedx that i
had a pleasure of seeing talks about
this idea of career development and
and this you know how to make the most
of your first 90 days
and so before we get to that arnon tell
me a little bit about your background
and and what sort of led you throughout
your career until now
um so yeah so my background is um
i have an engineering degree and then an
mba um
my engineering degree from a technion
and then mba from tel aviv university
and i've actually had um i would say two
very different careers the first one was
with i.t
or information systems um and i spent
um a couple few years actually almost
seven years in the israeli navy
working on information systems and then
as you mentioned in a company called
ness
and then my second career which has been
for the past 20 years
has been with consumer electronics
companies
and i've done various roles in each of
these different careers
but it's really about um i think
seizing the right opportunity when it
comes along
and part of that and part of making sure
you have those opportunities or that
they
present themselves is really the network
of people that you have and i would even
call it just
friends and people that you're friends
with because
you know i think about it at the end of
the day all of the
great opportunities i've had and i was
lucky to have had them
was because i had you know a friend who
knew me and
thought highly of me and thought i could
add value
to a certain company and that's how i
was presented with these opportunities
and so how how have you seen it actually
play out in these experiences you're
mentioning that at the end
you know it's the the network that you
bring with you not just you know the
you know the the linkedin network but
it's actually the people that are close
to you your inner circle that are the
ones that are presenting these unique
opportunities
what i'm hearing you know between the
lines that it's a lot about trust
right it's a lot about this trust that
you build that at the end transcends
into these new opportunities so how does
that actually play out
um it's exactly about trust and it's
about
a certain credibility that you have with
people and again you can't
you know be friends with everybody and
to be honest you shouldn't probably and
you can't have
that the same level of credibility with
everybody and vice versa
but it's again along the way whether
it's
through your personal life or work life
you meet people
um and again as an example
i was um i was selling sap systems in
israel this was my last role as
in in the it business and i got a call
from
um a very close friend who was with me
in the navy actually
and he said look i'm i'm now the gm of
this business unit
and we need a head of product marketing
and management
and you'll be a great fit and i told
them
how do you think i don't have any
experience in product marketing or
management
i've never done consumer electronics
i've never worked
in a global environment before so pretty
much
anything that i can think is needed for
this position i don't have
and he said yep but i know you and
you'll do great
um and i admit it took me a couple days
to think about it
but at the end of the day again when you
have somebody who believes in you
these are the breaks you need and it
that was definitely built
on our working together in this case in
the navy for seven years and getting to
know each other
very very well um so it's definitely
about
building that trust with people along
the way and it doesn't have to be
necessarily friends it could be partners
and suppliers and customers
i can give you a second example i was
working as a
vp for operations from modu which was a
startup company here in israel
and we set out to build the world's
smallest and lightest mobile phone
and we did for various reasons uh the
company did not
end up being a success and as i was you
know looking
through what i want to do next i got a
call from microsoft all the way from
redmond
um really halfway off the world
and part of the reason is they heard
about me
from some of our partners that i had in
modu
that microsoft is also working with um
and they told them look you know this
guy just became available you should
talk to him
um and again that's another example of
partners and suppliers who you had a
good right relationship with
um and eventually these things come back
to you a hundred percent so
you know i love how we're framing this
conversation about you know the
different values that
one should keep in mind as they go
through through their journey because
one of one of the things that i'm saying
and you know having you know i have the
the great pleasure of
wearing a few hats throughout throughout
you know the the past year or so which
is both you know as a student at
stanford with a lot of other
you know hungry scrappy students that
are you know that are thinking about
what to do but i'm also you know and in
hippo insurance and i get to see
internally within an organization how it
runs and how people progress and how you
build an incredible company but also in
all from an investor's perspective
how to how do you you know invest in in
companies
at the different stages and how do they
keep focus and build a great culture
so framing this about you know the
personal development i'm seeing a lot of
rush
i'm seeing a lot of competitiveness i'm
seeing a lot of people that you know are
joining companies
as a stepping stone they're not really
thinking about you know what they're
tangibly doing but what is what's going
to get me to the next
phase so i'd love to pick your brain on
some other values that one should keep
in mind
as they harness a new talent or join a
new organization
or or try to make that leap in their
career
um so a couple of things one of the
things that really opened my eyes and
and i have to admit in being with
microsoft as a gm
and i was there for seven years um
it's really incredible to see and
especially especially after asaki took
over the ceo
and that shift in corporate culture for
a ship that has a 120 000 people
and still it was so evident and clear to
feel that change within less than a year
one of the things that was amazing and i
know people tell me
oh this is a luxury that a big company
can have maybe
but when we had an opening and we hired
somebody
even if it was a very urgent you know
job opening that we needed to get
somebody in the door
the way we would look at this and and
this really kind of changed
um my view on hiring uh we would look if
somebody
can they be a good hire for microsoft
not just for this role for microsoft for
the next 10 years
are they going to be the right fit for
our culture
and i have to admit in some cases we
found somebody we thought is the perfect
candidate to come in and plug the hole
that we had
but we also didn't think it's the right
person to have joined the company
and that does not fit the culture that
we want to see
and we said no and we moved on um and
yes i admit you know when
you're a startup company you have 20
people you need somebody to come in and
do x or y
you don't always have that luxury i
completely get that
but i think the more you can at least
have those conversations
um and i can tell you today i'm on the
advisor board of a few startups here in
israel
one of them is going through exactly
that same process today we saw a
candidate
he's technically the person that we need
we don't know if it's the right fit and
we're having those discussions
um and for me i'm just happy that you
know that the ceo and cto the
co-founders are having those discussions
um and i think that shows a great deal
of maturity
and care about the type of company that
they want to build
right and so tell me a little bit about
how do you actually you know break down
that barrier because it's very easy
to give you know assessments that
you know we have data from you know
thousands of candidates that you know if
the candidate performs in the top five
percent of this assessment then they
would probably be a good
technological or skill set wise fit for
your culture
or for your company but not for
necessarily for the culture which is
much more fluffy right it's much more
subjective you know there's no one way
to test this
so how how do you advise you know even
young
founders that are looking to make their
hires how do you even go about assessing
whether
this person is a right fit or not
um i'll be honest and say i don't have a
um you know ready-made answer or process
do this do these steps and you're good
to go
um you know to some extent it's so much
easier
to hire based on hard skills and
technical skills
than it is based on soft skills um
there's a famous i'm sure everybody
heard about it the famous beer test is
this a person
that you want to want to go out for a
beer with um
i don't like that test because it it
actually allows for our bias
to only hire people we want to have as
friends and that's not the intent and
his managers
interesting it's not about hiring and
about hiring people who are good
for the company um so i would stay away
from that but
um i can tell you what we did at
microsoft and sandisk as well
we would have six seven uh people in an
interview loop
and we would uh write our comments again
not just on the technical skills but
mainly on the soft skills
or not mainly but my job was at least a
mainly look at the soft skills
and you know talk to people about um
challenges that they have and talk to
people about
i admit all these cliches that you can
read on websites the question that
people ask you and
sometimes we ask harder questions um my
favorite all-time question and it's kind
of the go-to question i always go
at the end of the interview is assuming
you join our team tomorrow how do you
make us better
and you know people would tell me i
don't know what your team needs or what
you know what gaps they have
and to me that didn't matter i used to
give them
this is a few years ago now i used to
give them the jj watt example
he was at the time the best defensive
player in the in the nfl
and i will tell him um you know what
doesn't matter which team
you put jj what on he's going to make
them
better defensively just because of who
he is his superpower is playing defense
um it doesn't matter you know which you
are um and that was my analogy and
um i you know when you join our team
tomorrow how do you make us better what
is your superpower
um and you know many cases people would
say i need to think about it which is
fine or it will just
try to flack up a conversation uh but
it really led to very interesting
replies and conversations with these
people
right and so you know talking about
culture talking about you know and the
relationships
and people starting out their their
careers what are some of the biggest
mistakes you're saying
so people that you know either you know
join companies start companies but
things that really you see repetitively
and they single again
we should they should be the next person
should be worried of that
so two things that come to mind um i
think one you mentioned it briefly
people look at companies as a stepping
stone
uh i'm just gonna do my two years stand
here and move on to the next place
right um even worse people actually
actually are loud and open and tell
people about it which is just
i think terrible but even the thought
process itself
um i think you want your first job or
you know the first 10 years of your
career uh to be with a good company that
you relate to the culture
and especially especially um to have a
great manager and i get it it's hard
to assess if the manager is a good
manager or not before you start
but i think that's what you need to look
at you want to have a great manager
right that looks out for you somebody
you learn with somebody that helps you
grow
somebody that gives you the right
opportunities within the company
and again if it's a good company and
there's so much information today online
and talk
to friends do your homework if it's a
company that
you hear from people it's a good company
to work for
and it's a good manager um i think you
know use truck gold and you should stay
there's as much as you can
i wouldn't worry when you start about
what's my next
move going to be because honestly um i
think most people really have no idea i
can again tell you
from my perspective i started micro in
it in sales
and right last position at microsoft
forcing and partnerships
so i think you really have no idea
um i think it's a always a good
thought and process and it's a good plan
to put a career plan in place but
especially keep an open mind and look
out for these opportunities because they
will
come along the way and again that that
plan
is only something that that you would
want to change later um anyway so just
be cognizant of that fact
um right and i think the second thing
that people
seldom think about when they start a
position in a new company
most people whether it's sales or
marketing or operations enforcing or
or whatever it is they look to the
outside if it sales people when i was
doing sales
people joined the company the next day
they want to be on a plane go see
customers and they would always ask him
why what value can you possibly bring to
your customer
on this you know first week second week
second month on the job
same with operations people they want to
go on the
suppliers and ask them why you don't
even know what the gaps are
i think people overlook the extremely
important process which in most cases
is a lot harder of building internal
partnerships
and whichever position you have you have
people inside the company that you need
to work with and partner with
and you know going back to what we said
before about trust
if you don't know how to build that
trust and credibility
um internally in the company to get to
the point where you can make an
influence and
eventually make an impact then you're
useless and and you can you know have a
great rapport with the customers or
suppliers
but if you don't know how to do that
internally uh you'll have a hard time
being successful
right now i i love those insights and i
think that these are things that i've
been
still you know learning about about by
myself and about
sort of the the the values that i want
to bring towards you know whatever i do
which is either you know both with a
passion but also in terms of the culture
the relationships
and the right mindset to enter these to
enter these partnerships it's not just
about you know taking the check boxes
but it's about really learning through
these experiences
making sure that that you provide the
right value both to yourself
and to and to your manager it's it's a
two-way street right it's not just
you know um it's it's not one side where
one side is just pleasing the others but
it has to be a win-win situation for
everybody
and on we you know your career is is
just from and
having had the opportunity to you know
be management in sales and partnerships
and
operations and r d you know it's there's
so many different things that i would
want to ask you but you know given that
we just have a few minutes left
i have to ask you a little bit about you
know the the idea behind partnerships
and growing scalable partnerships you
know you're advising companies on how to
do this
what have you found as you're sitting
you know on you know the leadership of
these fantastic companies like sandisk
and microsoft and nes
what does it take to build really
meaningful partnerships
um it's actually a really powerful
question and
and i think one of the things i learned
throughout my career
is um you can read all the negotiation
books and trust me i have and it's
really easy to see
um especially maybe i was the younger
people in their careers today
when they come in to negotiate you can
kind of after 10 minutes
understand which is their go-to book and
what is their strategy
um at the end of the day this is gonna
sound like a terrible cliche but it's
really really not and i'll give you an
example
um it's really about building a
partnership as opposed to i'm going to
get the most
from that company and hopefully they
won't from us um and it's really about
first of all during your homework you
need to understand
what right the other side of the table
they need as a company
um and especially the person the team
the people who are sitting across the
table from you
what do they need what do they need to
come back to their
you know headquarter with is going to be
a success
and and you'd be surprised in many cases
people don't even hide that they'll be
happy to have that conversation and say
look
this is what we need and i'm not naive
to think that people will always share
everything and again i know how it works
but when you come in with that
point of view and that approach um again
i was surprised
of how much people love to play along
um and understand how to do things
one of the first huge agreements i had
with microsoft was with a big partner
in japan and i've known this company for
my m-step systems incentive days
for many years and it took us a year and
a half to negotiate and
teams went back and forth and they could
just not land on an agreement
um eventually i met the gm of that
company
at ces this was i guess five six years
ago
and um we had 10 people or
something like that from each side and
the teams are still going at it
eventually he says stop it takes me
outside we go out
again this is vegas we go out to the
casino he said
if you tell me i know you for 12 years
if you tell me that i can trust you
um with you know the intent of what we
wanted to get out of this agreement even
if we can't put it in writing
i'm good to go and i looked at him and
again i'll keep
his name with me and i told him we're
good to go you can trust me you know me
and he said we're done we went back in
and we were done and that agreement
still holds today
um and again it's not because we're
friends or because he liked me as a
person because he knew me and how i do
business and he knew that i
care about him meeting his objectives
and that's important to me and i'm going
to make sure that that happens
of course my first priority and that was
on the table as microsoft
as it should be but at the end of the
day if you care about
the other side and want with this to
really be a partnership
um again i'm not naive i'm the last
person you can call naive
uh but it really works i love it
arnon thank you so much for your time
and for the inspiration i love the
values that you bring to the table
both in terms of the career development
but also in terms of
you know building the right partnerships
and at the end at the end of the end it
comes down to trust it comes down to
trust both you know the other person
that you're working with partnering with
or trust with yourself of being honest
about
what your intentions are and being very
transparent about those intentions with
the people you work with in your manager
and making sure that those intentions
are aligned right and i think that
what part of what what i've been saying
is that sometimes these intentions are
not aligned
and and that's why hiring is hard right
and
people say higher higher slow fire fast
particularly for those reasons so arnon
thank you for the time of inspiration
and the most
important question three words that you
would use to describe yourself
um yeah 19 minutes is not a long time
i would say that the first one is is i'm
a
learner i like to ask questions i like
to read
i like to listen um and when you think
about it how many people you know
that really like to listen and are
actually good at it
and listen with the intent of actually
listening and not
just saying what you have to say um i
think the second thing is um
determined and i think that word really
speaks about
ambition but it's more than that it's
about the relentless
nature i think i would say of achieving
your goals
and the discipline especially the self
discipline that is required and i think
self-discipline is something that
um self-motivation is something that
i've read tons of books about it
something that i think is extremely
important
um and the last the third word i would
use
is people um and i've had a conversation
two or three weeks ago with somebody
about you know introverts and extroverts
and am i a type of a person who gets
energized by people
or needs energy to go be around people
um and i think at the end of the day
most
you know most cases uh more often than
not
i would prefer to be around people and
and
have um a dynamic that involves people
obviously would love that to be my
friends it doesn't have to be i like to
make new friends and i really
think that you know doing what we do in
working with
teams of people and being around people
is really what drives all these
companies
and the energy forward and i think i
look at all the companies i've been to
from m systems our culture was people
first
to microsoft and it was the same um it's
really about the people that are
the most important asset that these
companies have
i love it arnon thank you so so much
this was wonderful
and stay safe and stay healthy and and i
truly appreciate it thank you
thanks a lot